[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24 le
20e congrès du Parti communiste chinois
c'est ouvert avec le discours de Sea
Jinping le président chinois s'est
exprimé pendant près de deux heures
devant plus de 2300 délégués du parti au
palais du peuple de Pékin il a défendu
sa politique zéro covid et évoquée les
questions de sécurité il a expliqué que
la Chine ne renoncera jamais à l'usage
de la force pour obtenir la
réunification de Taïwan et prendrait
toutes les mesures nécessaires pour
bloquer tout mouvement séparatiste si
Jinping devrait être reconduit pour un
troisième mandat comme secrétaire
général du parti alors si junking est-il
l'homme le plus puissant de Chine depuis
Mao est-il en passe de devenir l'homme
le plus puissant du monde y a-t-il un
risque de guerre entre les États-Unis et
la Chine
tout-puissant on en débat avec mes
invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir mes
côtés Jean-François d'immiglio bonsoir
bonsoir économiste également président
de l'agia à déjà bienvenue à vous en
face de vue en face de vous Marie Oldman
bonsoir sinologue et présidente de
solidarité Chine bienvenue à vous
également dans le débat shinyan lea est
avec nous fondatrice de Faida Consulting
merci d'être là à chignane et puis
également en face de vous et Thierry
volton bonsoir Thierry volton essayiste
spécialiste des régimes communistes et
postes soviétique auteur d'une histoire
mondiale du communisme ces trois tomes
c'est ça
et en voilà donc la couverture ça
évidemment un lien direct avec ce débat
merci d'être là le 20e congrès du Parti
communiste chinois s'est ouvert dimanche
on va revenir d'abord sur le discours de
chez Jinping en images
une mise en scène bien orchestrée pour
l'ouverture de son congrès le Parti
communiste chinois accueille sous un
tonnerre d'applaudissements les 2300
délégués du PCC sont venus de toute la
Chine dans son discours d'ouverture chez
Jean Ping défend son bilan et sa
politique draconienne de lutte contre le
covid de plus en plus contestée
nous avons placé la population et les
vies humaines au-dessus de tout
nous avons persévéré avec ténacité dans
une politique dynamique de zéro covid en
lançant une guerre totale très populaire
pour arrêter la propagation du virus
ce congrès est crucial Jing ping devrait
obtenir un troisième mandat consécutif à
la tête du parti il est parvenu à
écarter ses rivaux à coups de purges
spectaculaires officiellement au nom de
la lutte contre la corruption une
politique qui la vivement défendue
la lutte contre la corruption a remporté
une victoire écrasante et a été
consolidée de manière exhaustive
éliminant les graves dangers latents au
sein du parti de l'État et de l'armée
sur la place Tiananmen les policiers
sont partout pour éviter toute
contestation le Congrès doit durer
jusqu'à samedi prochain et tout est fait
pour que l'événement se déroule sans
accroc
on a vu donc 2300 délégués du parti
était commun seul homme derrière si
Jinping qu'en est-il des Shanghai
alors difficile de savoir exactement ce
qu'en pensent les Chinois puisque sur
les réseaux sociaux toutes les
publications officielles qui ont trait
au congrès sont fermés aux commentaires
donc pas de réaction possible qu'elle
soit positives ou négative en revanche à
Pékin jeudi une banderole a été déployée
par un manifestant et ses banderoles sur
l'une d'entre elles demandaient la
destitution de sidin ping une autre de
critiquer notamment la politique zéro
covid c'est un événement complètement
incroyable en Chine qui demande un
courage assez exceptionnel et
l'événement a été censuré des réseaux
sociaux chinois toutes les images ont
disparu et encore aujourd'hui on ne peut
pas chercher le hashtag Pékin sur
l'Internet chinois et pour revenir au
Congrès le discours inaugural dont on
avait entendu quelques extraits a été
très suivi hier on a vu sur les réseaux
sociaux des images de d'université de
clubs de sport ou encore de mariage ou
tout s'est arrêté le temps d'écouter le
discours de chez Jean Ping et aussi le
discours était aussi suivi c'est parce
que de nombreux Chinois avaient encore
un peu l'espoir de voir les mesures
sanitaires s'a légère mais dans son
discours si Jean Ping a assumé et
maintenu le cap de sa politique zéro
covid donc cela ça a provoqué de la
déception notamment à Shanghai ou les
confinements locaux se multiplient à
nouveau mais cette déception elle doit
rester discrète merci
on va revenir évidemment sur la
population et avant cela ce vingtième
congrès du pccès est-ce qu'on peut dire
qu'avec ce congrès si Jinping devient
l'homme le plus puissant de Chine depuis
Mao
qui est pas beaucoup de doutes en tout
cas
jusqu'à ce que la situation se retourne
c'est-à-dire que pour l'instant on est
en train d'atteindre un paroxysme de
toute puissance alors la toute-puissance
ça connaît des cycles
combien de temps se cycle dure-t-il
ma lecture de la Chine c'est que elle a
traversé toujours des cycles on est
clairement dans un cycle de renforcement
de fermeture de durcissement de
sittingisme si Jinping on peut le dire
de seging is the city billies après on
verra si c'est effectivement du
communisme si c'est
néo-maoïsme si c'est un maoïsme digital
donc indéniablement au moment où nous
parlons devant les délégués que vous
avez montré il est l'homme le plus
puissant de Chine mais écoutez l'avenir
nous dira combien de temps ça dure tu
révolton est-ce qu'il est obnubilé par
l'effondrement de l'Union soviétique oui
bien sûr c'est évident vous savez les
Chinois avec beaucoup beaucoup
d'intérêts ils ont étudié comment
s'était passé
[Musique]
et donc il craignent beaucoup un
pourrissement de la situation et c'est à
dire durcissement de chez limping vient
de là c'est à dire que l'ouverture qui a
été faite à partir de des années 80-90
plutôt 90 d'ailleurs parking le
gouvernement actuel est si ink
particulièrement fait en sorte que
disons l'huile qui a été mis dans les
rouages économiques ne viennent pas
pourrir les esprits et donc il y a une
reprise en main idéologique considérable
et c'est vrai que ils sont obsédés par
un processus
gorbatchevia qu'il craignent énormément
pour l'instant il n'a aucun risque
excusez moi la Chine n'est pas prêt de
suivre un processus gorbatchi vous êtes
d'accord elle est pas prête du tout de
suivre justement ce côté grand match et
bien comment a-t-il fait si Jean Ping là
effectuer des purges déjà au sein du
parti on a parlé de 6 à parachi très
proche de lui pendant ce 20e congrès
oui c'est vrai c'est proche de ce qui
pouvait se passer au sein du parti
soviétique à l'époque les partis
communiste oui mais où est-ce que c'est
proche de finalement de ce que faisait
Mao aussi
le nouveau arrive et ceux qui étaient
avant qui disparaît
vous avez posé la question est-ce qu'il
devient l'homme il est le plus fort du
pays depuis 10 ans
manifestement il s'est arrangé tous les
pouvoirs il a créé des commissions
Haddock dont il s'est nommé lui-même
président et là en 2018 il a décidé tout
seul que il ne quitterait pas le pouvoir
et qu'il continuerait donc il a modifié
la Constitution modifié la Constitution
donc il reste l'homme le plus fort de
Chine et donc quelque part du monde
parce que personne n'a aucun autant de
pouvoir que lui chez une Linux ce que
vous êtes chinoise la seule je dirais de
ce panel est-ce que pour vous il est
effectivement devenu l'homme le plus
puissant de Chine depuis Mao
moi je n'ai pas connu l'époque moi donc
c'est difficile de comparer s'il est
plus puissant que moi ou pas mais oui je
pense qu'il est l'homme le plus puissant
de la Chine depuis 10 ans voilà puisque
il participe à la prise de décision les
plus importantes pour lâcher donc c'est
au ping en fait avait limité le nombre
justement de mandats à deux c'était lui
pour éviter un pouvoir totalitaire il
revient en fait sur cette réforme si
Jean Ping oui il a changé la
Constitution en 2018 je crois et je
pense que cela a été perçu différemment
au sein du parti aussi au sein de la
Chine parce que au sein du parti il y a
aussi des avis partagés mais je crois
que cette fois-ci lors du 20e congrès il
sera probablement réélu voilà de nouveau
et donc il fera un troisième mandat il y
a pas eu de dissension plus que ça au
sein du parti Jean-François Dimeglio il
a tout de même effectivement modifié la
Constitution alors que c'est dings qui
voulait éviter que on fasse plus de
demanda il effectuer un certain nombre
de purge quand même quand il est arrivé
on le sait c'est monolithique
aujourd'hui derrière lui le parti le
parti n'a jamais été monolitique il y a
pas de raison que le parti demeure
monolithique si il y a le moindre la
moindre 11 de démocratie en Chine si on
doit la chercher ce qui ressemble le
plus probablement c'est le débat au sein
du parti ceci étant dit il y a un débat
aujourd'hui au sein du parti alors déjà
sur le fait qu'il le renouvelle un
mandat parce que personne autour de la
table n'est membre du parti est donc un
accès au type de débat qu'il peut y
avoir on ne peut pas ignorer qu'il y en
ait simplement il s'incarne aujourd'hui
d'une façon très très différente de ce
qu'on a pu connaître effectivement
lorsqu'on avait par exemple
un
groupe dirigeant de cette personne ou 9
personnes qui représentaient chacun des
factions
aujourd'hui faction aujourd'hui même
s'il y a des représentants supposés
d'une faction de Shanghai une faction de
de la Ligue du parti probablement qui se
sont alignés néanmoins quand on écoute
avec un peu d'attention le le maximum
d'attention qu'on puisse déployer et le
peu qu'on puisse entendre de nos amis
chinois on sait bien que ni le parti ni
la Chine ne sont totalement alignés sur
les positions qu'il faut prendre
aujourd'hui simplement il n'y a pas
d'espace pour les exprimer et il y a
encore moins d'espace pour garder sa
liberté si jamais on les exprime Thierry
valtoise il a une stratégie léniniste au
sein du parti écoutez en tout cas il est
clair pour moi que le Parti communiste
chinois dans son fonctionnement est un
parti communiste les ministres c'est à
dire il répond à un c'est assez simple
en vérité les fonctionnements de la
partie Lini c'est quoi c'est une
idéologie et n'a pas d'autre et de fait
il y a aucune autre possibilité dans en
Chine d'exprimer une autre idéologie
un dirigeant suprême c'est le cas en
tout cas aujourd'hui et donc et un parti
monolithique et qui dirige tout vous
vous dites monolithique monolithique
dans le sens je veux dire il y a pas il
y a pas d'autres parties que lui qui
dirige y compris des entreprises alors
on vous dira les quelques personnes vous
diront mais il y a quand même des
représentations de certaines minorités
etc de certains pseudo-parties pour
faire un peu démocratique mais ça c'est
de l'habillage il y avait la même chose
dans le milieu soviétique vous savez
donc c'est ça un régime des nid c'est ça
donc aujourd'hui en tout cas il atteint
son paroxysme aujourd'hui absolument il
est revenu à des fondamentaux si on
pourrait dire et donc on va voir ce que
ça va donner parce que c'est un peu en
contradiction par rapport à l'évolution
du monde quand même quelque part
vous êtes d'accord on a parlé du rapport
tout de même des droits de l'homme sur
la question des Ouigours le rapport de
l'ONU on a vu cette banderole elle en
parlait justement notre correspondante
cette banderole d'opposition qui a duré
très peu de temps mais enfin on l'a
quand même vu on a vu aussi pendant la
période covid toutes ces tous ces
opposants à Shanghai c'est hurlements de
chinois enfin on sent même qu'il y a une
société qui est pas forcément tout à
fait d'accord avec ce qui se passe mais
les musées en fait aujourd'hui je crois
qu'on est arrivé à un degré presque
ultime d'une société totalitaire c'est à
dire qu'on n'a pas le droit d'exprimer
autre chose que ce qu'on vous dit
d'exprimer mais comme disait
Jean-François tout à l'heure la Chine
est cyclique et c'est souvent des cycles
de 10 ans en 1979 on a eu un premier
printemps de Pékin tout d'un coup on a
découvert que les Chinois avaient envie
de plus réalisme de syndicats autonomes
de droits de l'homme de d'élection de
différents
économiques étaient mises en place hop
tout le monde était mis en prison
weinson a fait 15 ans de prison après
1989 c'était la même chose mais cette
fois-ci c'est toute la Chine qui est
descendue dans la rue en luttant contre
le dépotisme pour la démocratie pour le
dialogue etc là donc shopping il avait
plus de monde en face la répression a
été plus violente on a envoyé les tanks
donc on est que dans une répétition de
cycle là
et et et bon après on vous dit de 10 ans
ça lui laisse peu de temps
c'est une façon de parler un peu hein
mais en 1999 on a vu dimanche réformes
économique qui ont vraiment secoué toute
la Chine ça a été ça a été dur pour
beaucoup d'entre eux parce qu'ils ont
perdu ce qu'on appelait le bol de riz en
fer il fallait se lancer dans l'économie
privée le business et tout s'en sortir
trouver son propre logement etc et puis
maintenant on est dans le l'intelligence
artificielle et la surveillance absolue
donc si Jinping en quelque sorte
vraiment bétonné le climat ambiant mais
je pense sincèrement et tous mes amis
autour de moi que les chinois sont des
gens comme les autres si j'osent dire
c'est-à-dire qu'ils aiment leur liberté
ils aiment le plus réaliste mais qui
n'ont pas le choix non pas le choix
signalique je vous qui travaillent avec
les entreprises notamment entreprises
françaises cette image d'un site Jinping
tout puissant de enfin ce qu'on décrit
est-ce que ça ne nuit pas est-ce que ça
n'est pas nuisible parce que les
entreprises ont toujours envie de
s'installer en Chine est-ce que ça leur
fait pas un peu peur
les gens se contrôlent français
occidental je pense que c'est que les
préoccupe le plus c'est l'impact concret
sur leur activité économiques sur la
production
l'approvisionnement la vente etc c'est
vrai en ce moment il y a une certaine
défiance
défiance gluten d'inquiétude et aussi de
d'incertitude aussi face à ce qui se
passe en Chine actuellement parce qu'on
est dans une phase qui a un peu je
dirais une phase de transition pour moi
mais on peut parler de cycle par le
transition parce que
je dirais pour les grandes sociétés qui
sont déjà présentes là-bas comme le
couple L'Oréal LVMH
à long terme toujours un marché
important je pense que le seront
toujours là tant que cela reste rentable
mais c'est vrai que à court terme il y a
beaucoup de questions qui se posent
voilà sur quand la Chine pourra ouvrir
de nouveau sa porte voilà et je pense en
ce moment parce qu'on a avant 20e
congrès on attendait qu'il y aurait des
à supplément des mesures ont dit covid
là c'est clairement dit durant le
congrès que voilà qu'on allait continuer
continuer la politique justement
anticoïde voilà par contre je pense que
qu'on ne pourrait pas garder la
politique de zéro covid à jamais c'est
impossible donc il faudrait un moment je
pense qu'on attend un moment qui qui
serait approprié aux yeux du
gouvernement pour pouvoir faire une
transition de politique effectivement
changer cette politique zéro covid on va
y revenir mais tout d'abord on va parler
de Taïwan puisque c'est jimping a été
particulièrement applaudi quand il a
évoqué la question de la réunification
de la Chine de Taïwan il a expliqué
d'ailleurs que la Chine ne renoncera
jamais à l'usage de la force pour
obtenir cette réunification et qui
prendrait aussi toutes les mesures
nécessaires pour bloquer tout mouvement
séparatiste on l'écoute
la résolution de la question de Taïwan
et la faire du peuple chinois lui-même
et elle doit être résolue par le peuple
chinois seul nous
œuvrerons avec la plus grande sincérité
et les plus grands efforts pour une
réunification pacifique de Taïwan mais
nous ne renoncerons jamais
au recours à la force
et à quelle échéance parce qu'en fait
les Taïwanais ont peur alors enfin eux
parle de 2020
avec la menace la population taïwanaise
est consciente du risque mais
n'est pas angoissé par le risque parce
que elle s'y préparent et elle est en
train de changer elle est en train de
prendre conscience aussi qu'elle a des
ressources et ça c'est tout à fait
nouveau parce qu'on a vécu une période
d'insouciance qui tenait à la grande
prospérité de Taïwan qui tenait aussi à
cette euphorie il faut rappeler que
Taïwan est passé de l'État d'autocratie
comme on le voit encore en Chine à
l'état de démocratie extrêmement active
extrêmement vivante de démocratie
directe à partir de 1987 et avec une
évolution qui s'est accélérée dans les
dernières années donc cette population
elle sait maintenant ce qu'elle a à
défendre et elle prend conscience
contrairement à cet insouciance qui
était la sienne que elle a peut-être des
moyens y compris la civile et dansant ça
elle n'est pas sourde elle sait bien que
la menace existe pour autant est-ce
qu'elle a peur elle n'a pas peur mais
les dirigeants sont forcément inquiets
et c'est pour ça que les dirigeants nous
demandent et je pense que en tant que
nationaux
occidentale et démocratie occidentale
nous devons entendre cet appel que ce
que représentait one n'est pas
simplement une partie de la Chine ce que
représente Taïwan c'est aussi une partie
de la démocratie et des systèmes ouverts
qui règnent un peu partout dans le monde
et qui sont représentés aussi en Asie
donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut penser à
Taïwan c'est effectivement la lutte
contre la démocratie et l'autocratie
pourquoi pourquoi
est-ce que pour les Chinois comme si
Jinping mais il est pas le seul ce n'est
qu'une seule Chine Taïwan parce que bon
alors que vous avez pour résumé
quand vous avez dit qu'il était
particulièrement
congrès lorsqu'il apparaît Taïwan et la
rédification il faut savoir que tout ça
est réglé à la minute même hein
vous avez des gens qui font bref c'est
pire qu'un show télévisé cette affaire
là donc les applaudissements sont au
temps naturels que bon bref en ce qui
concerne Taïwan je voulais quand même
dire quelque chose c'est que c'est c'est
vrai que alors bon il y a un discours
nationaliste de si Jinping qui est
incontestablement celui qui est tenu
mais ce qui gêne le plus dans Taïwan
pour le gouvernement chinois et pour les
communistes chinois c'est que la
prétention de du commissaire chinois et
de penser que finalement l'idéologie
communiste est tout à fait adaptable et
formidablement adaptable avec le
confucianisme et c'est important parce
que excusez-moi Taïwan est aussi une
perte de confucianisme et donc et c'est
une démocratie formidable donc c'est un
contre-exemple qui est excessivement
dangereux idéologiquement c'est c'est
bien plus dangereux que n'importe quoi
pour le parti communiste parce que
excusez-moi pour un parti communiste qui
est le plus important c'est l'idéologie
si un contre-exemple idéologique avec
des mêmes populations des mêmes cultures
que que eux c'est autre exemple qui est
terrible qui peut éventuellement donner
des idées à des chinois du continent et
là je veux dire c'est un risque qui est
bien plus important que ton chose à mon
avis
je vous donne la parole juste après
Marion escam votre avis ils vont finir
par effectivement intervenir
militairement parce que manifestement
les Taïwanais ne souhaitent pas être
unifié à la continentale parce que c'est
le grand rêve de chez Jean Ping parce
que pour rentrer dans l'histoire il
faudrait quelque part qui réunit fille
complètement la Chine mais il faut pas
perdre de vue
qu'il unifie qu'il unifie la Chine mais
il faut pas perdre de vue qu'il a quand
même écrasé Hong Kong et que le monde
occidental n'a pas réagi on compte
c'était la partie encore démocratique de
la Chine et donc là maintenant Taïwan
n'a plus de protection Hong Kong c'était
un peu le tampon entre la Chine
communiste et la démocratie mais on va
écouter justement Joe Biden je vous fais
justement réagir juste après parce qu'on
va voir qu'il y a une différence entre
Hong Kong et Taïwan si on en croit le
président américain
en fait succession j'ai plusieurs points
à souligner premièrement il y a quelques
jours j'ai rencontré un
étudiant HEC venant de très loin lors
d'un événement à l'association HEC il
n’avait pas l'air tellement inquiet
deuxièmement si dans le discours
officiel du 20e congrès on a dit que la
Chine n'a pas donnerait pas la Fox si
nécessaire il y a une autre phrase quand
même avant ça c'est que la Chine
chercherait d'abord à résoudre le
problème de manière pacifique on dit
s'il y a une seule chance pour que cela
soit résolu de manière pacifique on
ferait des efforts pour vous c'est une
seule Chine
voilà donc ça c'est un premier point je
pense c'est quand même important temps
il faut pas exagérer c'est vrai qu'il y
a des tensions voilà il y a des il
faudrait résoudre ce problème c'est
aussi impacter à cause des provocations
américaines dans ces régions
deuxièmement je me demande pourquoi les
États-Unis sont tellement passionnés
pour intervenir dans la zone assez
Pacifique parce que les talons et les
Chinois de la Chine continentale nous
avons la même culture la même histoire
la même racine aujourd'hui il y a encore
des trésors qui ont été pris de de la
cité anthonique interactive qui sont
caractéris au Musée National justifie
non ça justifie rien j'explique les
choses ça c'est un premier point les
affaires chinoises moi je suis d'accord
qu'il faut laisser les Chinois se parler
entre s'asseoir et négocier pourquoi les
États-Unis veulent intervenir d'ailleurs
depuis des années dans les affaires des
autres pays ça sera la demande des
taïwanais
mais oui mais si on regarde le résultat
des interventions américaine dans
d'autres pays au Moyen-Orient en
Afghanistan on a eu quoi donc eux ils
sont là pour créer des
provoquer les Chinois pour provoquer les
tawanais pour provoquer la Chine
continentale mais cela apporte quoi mais
nous les Chinois on sait se parler on a
la même situation
un dernier point rapidement dernier
point rapidement rapidement est-ce que
vous comprenez pourquoi l'unité est
tellement importante pour les Chinois je
ne défends pas je dis je ne défends pas
la décision du gouvernement chinois mais
je voulais dire je souhaite sincèrement
que cela soit résolu de manière
pacifique et qu'il faut pas avoir trop
en inventions
occidentales
Pacifique possible et alors si si c'est
possible faisons référendum à Taïwan
c'est la seule manière pacifique madame
vous faites un excusez-moi laissez-moi
finir vous avez parlé vous avez parlé
donc je vous permettez donc vous faites
un référendum libre démocratiquement
surveiller par l'ensemble de la copie de
la de la coopération international et à
ce moment on verra qu'est-ce que se
disent qu'est-ce que décidera le peuple
taïwanais on est malade si le peuple
Taïwan il dit on veut pas être unifié
qu'est-ce que vous faites vous avez
l'armée alors est-ce que vous sais à ce
jour combien de pays qui ont admis que
que c'est la Chine y compris la France
politique ça n'a rien à voir en fait
finalement la France admet qu'il y a une
seule Chine officiellement mais demandez
mais demandez aux gens concernés en fait
si vous voulez avec du pacifié
les Chinois de la Chine continental et
Taounate discuter s'asseoir sur la même
table et négocier entre eux
la Chine vous savez l'accord vous
constituez consensus de 1992
très loin et la Chine inconnuementale
sont arrivés en accord pour dire qu'il a
une seule Chine la question
entre eux c'est important
intervenir dans les affaires intérieurs
en 1992 on était dans une démarche
typiquement diplomatique et c'est ce que
vous souhaitez et cette démarche
diplomatiques a obtenu ce résultat de
reconnaître une seule Chine mais aussi
de ne pas dire laquelle donc voilà à
quel résultat c'est une ça c'est une
consensus
est un processus de 1992 aujourd'hui ce
consensus apparemment ne tient plus
parce que les électeurs taïwanais comme
le dit Monsieur Walton ne sont plus
totalement en adhésion
si vous avez aussi confiance que ça dans
l'avenir de la Chine unique sous un
parapluie communiste
laisser les peuples s'exprimer les
signes qui vont suivre de la Chine
continentale moi je suis chinoise je
peux m'exprimer aussi donc je vous dis
pour moi le plus important c'est c'est
c'est la partage d'une même culture
d'une même histoire d'ailleurs je vous
dis quand je dis HEC ton autre promotion
il y avait une étudiante taïwanaise tous
les Chinois de la Chine continentale on
était très amicaux avec elle on sent
dans des très bien ça va me convient
parce que la question politique c'est
pas le plus important à la fin c'est la
paix Marie Oldman c'est pas les
interventions américaines qui nous
permet
effectivement
voilà répondre s'il vous plaît justement
cette question d'ailleurs les États-Unis
là sont beaucoup plus déterminés à
intervenir d'après ce qu'on entend que
du temps de Hong Kong
d'abord je
croisais ont toujours dit l'expression
pas autre chose si ange c'est à dire on
va garder le consensus actuel ne
bougeons pas restons comme ça on dit
qu'il y a une seule chose Chine nous on
est ici eux ils sont là ils changent de
langage comme ça c'est sûr mais pour le
moment c'est ce qu'ils espérait bon
maintenant la Chine devient de plus en
plus agressive il faut se rappeler que
la loi qui autorise la Chine enfin la
loi ou la Chine s'est autorisé à
utiliser les armes pour attaquer Taïwan
en cas de séparatisme comme ils disent
date de 2005 donc c'est quand même assez
vieux déjà mais ils ont fait ça de façon
unilatérale vous bougez on tire voilà et
puis on a d'un côté une démocratie qui
n'a aucune envie d'aller dans un système
totalitaire du temps du coming dingue my
Indio en particulier il disait mais il y
a aucun problème on veut bien retrouver
la Chine ou trouver la Chine si elle est
démocratique si elle n'est pas
démocratique on reste comme on est voilà
au Québec différence de système
politique en fait c'est ça je pose une
simple question les États-Unis ont
intervenu au Moyen-Orient ou dans
d'autres pays
avec ça si au nom de la démocratie ou au
nom de leurs propres intérêt voilà je
laisse c'est une question ouverte alors
est-ce que les deux peuvent se rejoindre
c'est ça la question ça c'est une bonne
question moi au moins on a le droit de
poser la question voilà Jean-François
guimiglio
effectivement la seule façon la seule
façon de de rejoindre les deux c'est
c'est d'écouter ceux qui ont ceux qui
ont quelque chose à dire et donc c'est
les personnes
la diplomatie chinoise est-elle de plus
en plus agressive par exemple vis-à-vis
même de bon ya Taïwan puis il y a
d'autres îles dans le sud de la mère de
Chine est-ce que il y a plus
d'agressivité alors il y a certainement
un ton il y a certainement aussi ce
qu'on a tendance très souvent à occulter
la perception je ne dirais pas de menace
mais de faiblesse en fait très souvent
vous savez quand on parle fort c'est
parce qu'on se sent pas aussi fort qu'on
voudrait que les autres le perçoivent et
on constate bien que plus les problèmes
internes de la Chine grandissent plus
cette agressivité grandit donc je pense
que la meilleure chose que nous
puissions faire si ça nous était permis
ce serait effectivement de en Chine ce
serait si le signe ne voulait bien qu'on
l'aide effectivement à se développer
selon le modèle qu'elle semblait suivre
depuis quelques années les choses
iraient peut-être mieux si effectivement
la Chine retournait on fait quand même
depuis très très longtemps non des
coopérations économiques avec la Chine
et aujourd'hui effectivement
il faudrait attendre après il faudrait
passer plus de temps à trouver une
meilleure solution pour la coopération
ainsi voilà un mot un mot peut-être sur
les liens avec la Russie Thierry vol
justement pour faire le lien entre ce
qui se passe évidemment côté Taiwan et
Chine et ce qui se passe en Ukraine
est-ce que ce qui se passe en Ukraine
fait tout de même réfléchir si Jinping
sur justement une intervent une
intervention possible ou probable à
Taïwan je pense que oui effectivement et
je pense que enfin évidemment j'ai
aucune hypothèse j'ai aucun je suis pas
un secret des dieux ni certainement pas
au bureau politique du parti communiste
chinois mais je pense que
ils ont observé d'abord la situation
avec beaucoup d'intérêt je pense que si
jamais le plan de Poutine avait réussi
c'est-à-dire si au bout de 4-5 jours une
semaine peut-être 15 jours il avait
réussi à envahir totalement l'Ukraine et
mettre un gouvernement fantoche c'est là
ce serait sans doute encouragé les
Chinois peut-être eux-mêmes essayer une
opération de force à Taïwan sachant que
les Occidentaux ont été un peu débordés
peuvent pas de feront la foi c'est très
compliqué stratégiquement parlant donc
en vérité je pense que les la résistance
ukrainienne à quelque part peut-être
qu'on le sera plus tard dans les livres
d'histoire quelque part sous vide
d'une à court terme peut-être à court
terme
en ce qui concerne l'Ukraine assez
solidaire pour l'instant attendez c'est
une histoire assez longue tout ça c'est
ça ça passe finir de ma matin pour
l'instant elle est effectivement une
alerte pour Pékin parce que il se disent
bon finalement les Occidentaux qui sont
assez faibles ils l'ont montré en
Afghanistan n'est-ce pas et ailleurs
encore finalement quand il se met
d'accord peuvent être assez forts donc
je pense que ça peut réfléchir à
réfléchir actuellement le gouvernement
Taïwan
2049 parce que si j'ai bien compris
c'est 2049 la date fatidique
et à ce moment-là il souhaiterait une
Chine réunie il aura 95 ans
on parle de l'intervention des
Américains je pense que il faut voir que
en unifiant Taïwan et la Chine les
Chinois vont s'arranger le priv de
considérer que tout le détroit toute la
zone maritime leur appartient et ça
c'est quelque chose qui fait très peur
non seulement aux Américains mais au
japonais aux Australiens les Philippins
se sont plaints devant la cour de la
haine la Cour internationale parce que
il pensait que les Chinois étaient en
train d'essayer d'un excès des petites
îles Philippines et qui ne voulaient pas
les philippins ont gagné et la Chine
c'est assise de sur le sur le procès en
disant ça nous concerne pas et c'est ça
qu'il faut il faut tous se background
pour comprendre que si le détroit de
Taïwan est bloqué par la Chine à ce
moment-là les Japonais n'auront plus de
pétrole par exemple ça c'est un gros
gros problème c'est un énorme impact et
c'est là peut-être que les intérêts bien
compris pour me rejoindre la
problématique démocratique je veux dire
ça c'est des analyses des choses qui ne
sont pas encore arrivées on ne sait pas
voilà il y a plein de choses qui
dépendent finalement aussi des
négociations il faut aussi connaître
l'histoire de Taïwan et de cette
Pacifique déjà j'ai vu des versions
différentes sur ces histoires et après
je me demande toujours est-ce que l'Asie
doit être protégé par les États-Unis je
comprends pas pourquoi excusez-moi le
Japon est en Asie il me semble enfin les
Philippines aussi sont en Asie monsieur
envoyer des bateaux près de près des
États-Unis elle a jamais fait ça donc
elle a pas encore fait je ne pense pas
qu'il a l'intention de le faire mais
pourquoi les États-Unis se permettent
en Asie Pacifique et je ne comprends pas
en tout cas on sent bien les tensions on
va revenir d'ailleurs sur la politique
interne à la Chine parce qu'il nous
reste un peu moins de 10 minutes est-ce
que l'économie est finalement le talon
d'Achille de la Chine on va revenir sur
sur cette question d'abord avec un
reportage de notre correspondante look
ici là justement à Shanghai qui évoque
cette politique zéro covid
la politique zéro covid vue de
l'intérieur ces vidéos prises dans une
bouche documente de très près le nouveau
rituel auquel se plie des centaines de
millions de Chinois chaque jour ces
images singulières sont l'oeuvre de ce
Yoann
on fait ces tests tellement souvent que
maintenant c'est devenu une partie de
notre quotidien
l'artiste veut interroger cette nouvelle
réalité il enregistrera ses tests tant
qu'ils seront obligatoires pour accéder
au lieu public ou voyager dans le pays
je préfère ne pas critiquer qui que ce
soit je veux juste montrer la réalité au
public pour que chacun se fasse sa
propre idée pour vivre en Chine il faut
se plier aux mesures sanitaires au nom
de la lutte contre le virus les
habitants peuvent être enfermés à tout
moment et à l'approche du 20e congrès du
Parti communiste les confinements se
multiplient ici les hommes en blanc
armés bouclent un aéroport pour
seulement une trentaine de cas dans la
région
il y a des centaines de personnes on ne
peut ni prendre l'avion ni sortir de
l'aéroport
ailleurs l'intégralité de la province du
signe Djang est en confinement stricte
alors que certaines zones ne comptent
aucun cas positif cette expatrié
français en vacances dans la ville de
cashgar et bloquée depuis 10 jours il y
a pas de covid ici on s'est fait toute
la ville a été testé les 7 derniers
jours donc il y a aucune raison valable
de de de d'emprisonner les gens chez eux
j'ai aucune idée de comment je vais
pouvoir partir d'ici
même à Shanghai deux mois de confinement
total au printemps n'ont pas suffi les
barricades autour des habitations
réapparaissent sous les yeux résignés
des habitants
je suis arrivé ce matin pour faire le
ménage et la police est venue nous
demander de rester ici on ne peut plus
partir
en ce moment les déplacements sont plus
que jamais restreint en Chine par
exemple un message d'erreur s'affiche
sur les téléphones de milliers de
personnes qui voulaient se rendre à
Pékin mais avec ce message impossible
d'embarquer dans un train ou dans un
avion direction la capitale transformée
en forteresse sanitaire
ça ennuie évidemment à l'économie
chinoise ce qui se passe 100 millions de
Chinois encore confinés alors
effectivement c'est quand même la grande
énigme est-ce que ça veut dire que
l'économie devient le talon d'Achille de
la Chine avec en plus aujourd'hui ils
ont décidé de reporter les derniers
chiffres de la croissance d'ailleurs oui
non c'est on a énormément on a
énormément d'indicateurs rappelez-vous
ce qui s'est passé autour du secteur
immobilier on voit bien que le secteur
financier qui a toujours été fragile n'a
pas été réformée et on voit bien que les
moteurs de croissance qui était quand
même en panne où on voit d'être en panne
ne sont pas repartis bien sûr tout ça
tout ça n'arrange pas les choses en fait
ce qui est très difficile à comprendre
c'est comment ce pays qui a toutes les
chances comme on l'a dit plusieurs fois
ici de prendre un certain de leadership
est en train d'une certaine façon de se
tirer une balle dans le pied parce que
s'il y avait quelque chose qui nous
intéressait qui nous fascinait c'était
cette capacité de la Chine à sortir les
personnes de la pauvreté c'était une
très belle réussite et on craint quand
même que non seulement la classe moyenne
qui était promise à l'accession un
certain niveau de richesse finalement ni
accède pas mais peut-être que le signe
régresse si ça continue shiny et elle
peut régresser cette Chine justement
d'un point de vue économique avec cette
politique elle le fait démographiquement
bien sûr est-ce qu'on parle est-ce que
est-ce qu'elle reste quand même le hub
de l'industrie mondiale aujourd'hui on a
vu que le secteur de l'immobilier
s'effondrait est-ce qu'il prend un
risque là effectivement si Jinping je
pense que comme il y a les plus et les
mois aujourd'hui c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui l'économie chinoise subit
une grande pression et c'est la demande
aussi de la durée en fait de la
politique actuelle de la gestion du
covid mais vous souhaiteriez qu'il
arrête ou moi je pense qu'il faudrait
qu'il soit arrêté au moment
approprié après personnellement j'aurais
aimé voir une sorte de simulation de
scénario avec des chiffres des données
c'est-à-dire entre différents scénarios
pourquoi on a pris une décision il y a
je n'ai pas vu en fait plus de détails
sur le processus de la prise de décision
je dirais que la communication du
gouvernement chinois et est assez à
Pâques d'ailleurs c'est un mode dans la
culture chinoise aussi c'est à dire en
Chine qu'on en chef prend une décision
il n'a pas ses obligations d'expliquer
en détail pourquoi donc moi aujourd'hui
il y a des choses que je comprends il y
a des choses que je ne comprends moi ce
que je souhaite et comme comme beaucoup
de mes amis chinois c'est que cette
pandémie se termine voilà d'une façon ou
l'autre après vous voyez bien la
différence avec les pays en Occident en
Europe ou plus personne porte de masque
enfin et d'ailleurs
différents c'est pour ça qu'on arrive
pas à se comprendre souvent et après je
pense que succès est un secteur par
exemple sur le marché automobile ou
d'innovation ou l'intelligence
artificielle etc il y a quand même
encore beaucoup de potentiels en Chine
voilà si elles veulent ton pourquoi une
telle politique c'est une compte du
contrôle de la part de Sydney
c'est sûr que c'est sûr que la peur de
la maladie le spectre de de la mort et
dit ben quelque chose qui est souvent
été utilisé par les pouvoirs pour
accélérer leur contrôle donc là
effectivement c'est une situation
formidable maintenant ce qu'il avait
besoin de ça j'en suis pas certain d'où
vient cette peur un peu irrationnel je
dois dire dans certaines mesures de ce
bon alors je comprends bien qu'il y a eu
beaucoup demeure des millions de morts
maintenant le monde entier à cause du
covid mais là on est dans une situation
surréaliste puisque dès qu'il y a trois
cas il bloque absolument tout donc là
c'est vraiment comme a été dit c'est une
balle qui serait dans le pied et à mon
avis c'est cette politique de
durcissement va avoir des répercussions
gigantesques sur sur l'économie bien
plus qu'on pense aujourd'hui d'abord
parce qu'elle va déjà assez mal cette
économie et donc je pense que et là je
crois que nous avons un système à une
espèce de d'assanne top de de la Chine
et nous allons assister calmement
lentement à un déclin de la Chine j'en
suis intimement convaincu et c'est alors
je finirai là-dessus et après je promets
jeter je pense que c'est une période
excessivement dangereuse parce que le
gouvernement chinois actuel qui croit sa
puissance qui croit à son avenir
puisqu'il parle il parle de 2049 qui
croit tout ça risque de se retrouver
dans une situation dangereuse vis-à-vis
de la population etc j'ai pas dit
qu'elle va se révolter j'entends bien à
monter une grande déception et qu'une
façon de rassembler ce peuple qui sera
un peu désillusionné par rapport à tout
ça c'est une poussée nationaliste très
forte qui existe déjà vers une agression
extérieure
moi j'ai lu que on appelle ça le pays du
c'est-à-dire c'est mer qui partent avec
leur fils qui ensuite la Chine le mari
reste en Chine et travail pour en fait
qu'il puisse avoir un revenu et elles
font tout pour partir pour élever leur
fils unique à Singapour enfin ailleurs
en Asie c'est un vrai phénomène ça ou la
plupart des hauts dirigeants on leur
famille à l'étranger si j'ai une ping en
premier sa fille avait ses études dans
les universités américaines elle est
retournée mais elle est retournée en
Chine sur les ordres de son père et on
dit qu'elle est repartie aux États-Unis
pour épouser un américain alors est-ce
que ça serait la classe moyenne éduquée
qui maintenant ferait ce type de choses
plus parce que il y a une politique
justement anticoïde non ça fait ça c'est
depuis au moins 40 ans que beaucoup
d'hommes d'affaires chinois demandent à
leurs collègues de les aider à donner un
visa pour que leur fille ou leur fils
puisse aller faire des études ailleurs
mais il est de plus en plus difficile de
quitter la Chine donc d'un autre côté ça
a freiné le phénomène mais là maintenant
puisque parle des enfants il y a plein
de jeunes qui veulent plus avoir
d'enfants qui disent dans un pays comme
ça moi je fais plus d'enfants donc c'est
aussi une forme de réaction vous
comprenez la déception de la classe
moyenne chinoise qui existe n'existait
pas il y a 50 ans sous le maïsme elle
existait grâce à l'enrichissement du
pays on estime à peu près à 250 millions
cette classes moyennes qui a commencé à
venir à Paris ailleurs de à voyager etc
et tout d'un coup elle se trouve
complètement bloquée et il est évident
que ça va poser des problèmes
gigantesques d'adhésion et de voilà là
je dis pas qu'il y avait des révoltes
mais ça va il peut y avoir je savais il
y a des moyens de résister dans les
pieds si je puis dire donc un ensemble
de facteurs quand même qui vont qui
poussent vers le déclin alors encore une
fois même si on parle beaucoup de la
rivalité d'ailleurs entre les États-Unis
et la Chine d'un point de vue
technologique il y a tout de même une
bataille là très forte le grand paradoxe
c'est que le parti a des capteurs
partout et ne peut que percevoir tout ce
que nous venons de dire enfin un facteur
démographique un facteur démographique
c'est pas compliqué à avoir et un
capteur d'opinion ou des migrations
c'est pas compliqué non plus avoir tout
se passe comme si on était bloqué en
nepercevant pas l'importance de ces
capteurs donc c'est pour ça que
d'ailleurs si vous avez et vous l'avez
entendu nous quatre nous sommes tous
d'accord ça ne peut plus tenir something
as to give même l'a dit je pense qu'il y
aura justement au bout d'un moment parce
que s'il y a beaucoup de pression
économique et psychologique aussi parce
que ça fait plus de deux ans et demi que
je n'ai pas pu revoir mes parents je
pense que les Chinois qui vivent à
l'étranger aimait bien aussi pouvoir
voir les membres de l'Europe famille
donc au bout d'un moment la presse les
pressions économiques et psychologiques
deviennent rompu corandre et c'est
possible qu'il y ait des ajustements
voilà mais ça veut dire changer de ligne
complètement
ça peut être aussi contre le peuple oui
et puis économiquement ça veut dire
quand même changer enfin avoir une ligne
peut-être moins dogmatique remettre un
peu d'économie de marché qu'on avait
fait d'excès au ping ou pas
le problème avec shejin ping c'est
qu'une fois qu'il a une idée en tête il
la lâche pas il y a eu beaucoup de son
idée c'est en un mot covid par exemple
c'était la lutte contre la corruption
c'est il a toutes sortes d'idées très
très fermées maintenant il veut
renationaliser les entreprises on a des
grands patrons comme Jack ma qui ont
fait en partie la fortune de la Chine
qui ont été anéanties etc etc et il n'a
jamais fait marche arrière il continue
sur sa ligne merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous il continue sur sa ligne en
tout cas merci beaucoup d'avoir
participé à ce débat mario'sman Thierry
volton merci je suis Niane le merci
Jean-François dimiglio et merci à vous
tous de nous avoir suivi vos restes avec
nos enfants ce 24
[Musique]